[Music]
breaking news this Friday night the
Prime Minister says enough is enough the
barricades must come down
what's pushed him to this point we can't
have dialogue when only one party is
coming to the table and what happens
next how will these blockades be removed
the new quarantine begins for about 200
Canadians plus new co vid 19 emergencies
in two countries Russian interference
the 2020 edition fresh warnings the
Kremlin is helping Trump win another
election and from Bulleid to bolster
their friend in May the international
show of support for a young boy and his
mother
[Music]
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with breaking news prime
minister justin trudeau says he has run
out of patience with the railway
blockades that have been crippling trade
and travel across the country the onus
he says is now on indigenous leaders to
end them
the barricades must now come down the
injunctions must be obeyed and the law
must be upheld Trudeau says his
government has exhausted every
possibility for dialogue with the small
group of what so and hereditary Chiefs
whose opposition to a natural gas
pipeline provoked the rail line
barricades shortly after the Prime
Minister made his position clear that
would sew it in Chiefs who have traveled
to Ontario responded it didn't include
any talk of ending the barricades now
there is a difference between the
inconvenience and injustice total
difference
don't confuse one with the other they
say they still want certain conditions
met before anything happens we'll get to
that in just a moment but first Eric
Sorensen on the prime minister's big
shift in position and whether it means
the barricades will come down senior
ministers huddled all day confronting a
dilemma slow moving talks and the fast
growing economic impact of indigenous
blockades and so a new tougher stance a
show of force that all of government has
done its best dialogue has not moved
things forward and that the Prime
Minister says now is unacceptable
Canadians have been patient our
government has been patient but it has
been two weeks and the barricades need
to come down now Prime Minister Trudeau
says the RCMP have agreed without
conditions now to take down the
controversial outpost on a service road
on the wet soil and land in northern BC
a core demand of the hereditary Chiefs
what now about reconciliation there is a
relationship to be renewed and new
relationships to be built Canada is
ready for this Canadians want this but
hurting Canadian families from coast to
coast to coast does nothing to advance
the cause of reconciliation the sudden
shift in tone suggests the economic
impact was hitting so quickly and so
hard across the country that the
government could not wait any longer the
economic impact is dire in the House of
Commons the first 20 questions from all
opposition parties showed the
frustration building from coast to coast
supplies of propane in eastern Canada
are reaching a critical level
eighty-five ships are in the Vancouver
harbour waiting to be loaded supermarket
shelves are starting to empty out the
Liberals have preached dialogue but it
was clear that patience for dialogue
quickly wore thin dialogue has its
limits mr. speaker the blockades must go
down the government says it's not for
Ottawa but for police to decide how best
and how quickly to respond to the
blockades conservative leader Andrew
Shearer says the Prime Minister should
do more than that he has refused to use
the authority that he has now he is
relying on the goodwill of the
protesters to take down the barricades
that's not leadership but the Prime
Minister is wary of the use of force in
terms of what happens next
Trudeau says the next move is up to the
wet so it and chiefs the onus is on them
Eric Sorenson Global News Toronto so one
of the would so it and cheeps is
sticking to his line now that nothing
will happen until the RCMP leave their
traditional territory in northern BC
you'll remember the police set up an
outpost there to enforce a court
injunction and remove a blockade on a
service road our Michael couture is in
tined Onaga Ontario that's where some
would sew it in Chiefs met with Mohawk
supporters today Mike did what the prime
minister said today mean they've changed
their position at all not really dawn
and they wanted to clarify that position
by inviting the media to speak with the
hereditary chiefs after that meeting
with the Mohawks here at the community
center and what they said was our
demands are
fold the first is that the RCMP
completely withdraw from the wet sort
and territory and we know the RCMP has
offered to go to Houston BC it's unclear
if that will be enough the second one is
that they want coastal gas link to
completely cease all operations in all
construction there and that they say
only after those two conditions are met
can they have true nation-to-nation
dialogue it could come in the form of
speaking directly with the prime
minister they are open to that they're
also open to speaking with either the
crown in indigenous relations minister
Carolyn Bennett or indigenous Services
Minister Mark Millar but they want to
make sure that that dialogue is started
but not before those two conditions are
met and they wanted to make it
abundantly clear for all Canadians and
for the prime minister have a listen we
demand the remote detachment community
industry service office established by
the RCMP over to attend territory
without our consent be immediately
removed and that the RCMP RCMP are
completely removed from our territory
and cease patrols from our lands of
means oh so what is it the protesters
where you are on Mohawk territory want
to bring the barricades down there yeah
they said that their demand has not
changed they will let the rails restore
Hut service and that the rail cars can
go by for one thing and that would be
that the RCMP withdraw from the wetsuit
and land the difficulty that we're
hearing now and in the community late
tonight
is that they are extremely nervous that
now that the prime minister says those
injunctions must be carried out and they
they must go through there's concern
that the Ontario Provincial Police will
move in as night falls here and
dismantle the barricades so Donna if you
thought that it was already tense before
because it is well that tension has just
been ratcheted up another notch all
right Michael cateura and Tyendinaga
territory in Ontario thanks it's finally
home time for a group of Canadians
caught in the chaos of the
kovat 19 outbreak two weeks after they
were airlifted out of Wuhan China a
group of people left cfb trenton free
from quarantine and back to their
regular lives but the clock has just
started ticking on a 14 day quarantine
of Canadians who were on board the
Diamond Princess cruise ship 129 of them
landed in Canada this morning Mike
Armstrong was there as the buses pulled
up in Cornwall Ontario they are going
from one 14 day quarantine to another
after two weeks on what some called a
floating prison the Canadian diamond
princess passengers home for the next
two weeks as a convention center there
in an isolated wing of the nav cane
facility a big improvement according to
one couple the Chows speaking from their
new room say they understand the
quarantine is to protect them and the
public I don't mind this 14 days both
myself and my wife we agree that we
should take this extra 14 days to be why
I was free
now in addition to the passengers
brought back there are about two dozen
other people being put in quarantine
anyone who came in contact with them on
the way back everyone from medical staff
and flight crew to the bus drivers some
will be evaluated if there wasn't much
contact they could be released early but
health officials are being careful as
far as I'm concerned people who are on
the cruise who will have to stay here
for 14 days there were fewer passengers
repatriated than expected about 70
Canadians declined the government flight
home and stayed in Japan having
completed the quarantine on the ship the
Japanese government is now letting them
off and they're free to move around the
country but when they return to Canada
they will be put in quarantine public
health officials say whether in a day a
week or three months from now two
governments are seeing the risk of
bringing back passengers from the
diamond princess Israel repatriated
eleven citizens and Friday announced one
has tested positive Australia
repatriated 30 and is confirming two
cases in each one the passengers tested
negative boarding the plane home and
positive once they arrived it's not
unexpected that some people might have
been incubating the virus kovat 19
ripped through the diamond
princess there were more than 600 cases
experts say something went wrong with
the quarantine the passenger is now back
in Canada will be checked twice daily
they're also being offered psychological
help to get them through the
understandable emotional stress Mike
Armstrong Global News Cornwall Ontario
and public health officials in British
Columbia are trying to figure out how a
woman contracted Cove aide 19 after
returning from Iran the woman in her 30s
is B C's sixth confirmed case and hers
is being described as unusual Iran only
confirmed its first CO vid 19 cases this
week the total official number of cases
there's 18 and four people have died
it's not clear where the BC woman picked
up the virus authorities here say it may
show the outbreak is more widespread
than what official numbers are showing
in South Korea authorities are
struggling to contain a fast spreading
outbreak there in one day the number of
cases has nearly doubled to more than
200 dozens of them are linked to a
fringe religious group in the city of
daegu and there's another emergency
unfolding in northern Italy 14 nuke Ovid
19 cases have been confirmed in a
handful of small towns bringing the
total in Italy to 17 schools restaurants
and businesses have been shut down to
try to stop the spread the federal
privacy watchdog is investigating if
Clearview AI the company behind
controversial facial recognition
software used by police violates
Canadian privacy laws the app
cross-references images of people
against billions of photos on the web
without consent
last month the New York Times revealed
the technology was already being used to
make arrests in the US and that prompted
global news to ask Toronto police if
there were using the software they
revealed the technology had been used
for months by officers without the
knowledge of the police chief police in
Toronto as well as Peel Halton and
Durham regions of Ontario since ordered
their officers to stop using it there
are new accusations the Russians are up
to their old tricks intelligence
officials have reportedly told American
lawmakers there's evidence Russia is
again attempting to interfere in the
presidential election and one of their
key goals is to get president Donald
Trump re-elected Jackson Provost
reports on the troubling new warning and
Trump's furious response despite running
for re-election on his record Donald
Trump is anxious to distance himself
from his past they said today that Putin
wants to be sure that Trump gets elected
here we go the president reportedly
became furious after learning that US
intelligence officials are once again
sounding the alarm about Russian
election interference in a classified
briefing lawmakers were told the Kremlin
is continuing its efforts from 2016
hoping to help reelect Trump the
president was upset that Democrats like
Adam Schiff were included in the
briefing fearing the information could
be used against him angry he fired his
Acting Director of National Intelligence
and appointed his ambassador to Germany
a fierce loyalist to the role it's just
information that's the only thing that
good at Russia called the accusations
from US intelligence officials paranoid
announcements but fears of renewed
meddling are not exactly a secret
Trump's own FBI director issued a public
warning earlier this month and have
never stopped seeing really since 2016
efforts to engage and malign foreign
influence by the Russians that influence
extends across party lines with word
that Democratic presidential candidate
Bernie Sanders has also been briefed by
US officials about Russian attempts to
help his campaign but the threat isn't
going away every member of Congress is
set to receive a briefing on election
security in the next two weeks amidst
warnings that Russia and other nations
are refining their meddling and
misinformation tactics Jackson prosto
Global News Washington
oil and gas companies promising to be
carbon neutral is that even possible
coming up a global national reality
check
the deadline for a big decision is
looming about a massive resource project
in Alberta the federal cabinet must
decide whether to approve the tech
frontier oil sands mine a 20 billion
dollar mega project proposed for
northeastern Alberta along with
producing crude it would also generate
about 4 million tons of greenhouse gas
emissions every year yet Tech and other
resource companies have vowed to reduce
their emissions to Net Zero is that
possible tonight Heather York's West has
a reality check two environmental groups
like Greenpeace the decision before
federal cabinet should be easy the
Trudeau government has joined other
countries around the world and answering
sort of the call of scientists saying we
need to get to zero emissions by 2050
and so we said you can't actually
approve a massive new oil sands mine to
operate until 2060 7 if you say we're
gonna be off fossil fuels 17 years
earlier but getting to Net Zero isn't
necessarily the same as getting off
fossil fuels entirely globally the
demand for oil and gas is not expected
to disappear for decades even as the
world begins to transition to a
low-carbon economy as long as there is
demand for fossil fuels somebody is
going to be supplying it still energy
companies have come to realize that as
global demands shift only the greenest
will survive it's why over and over
major players in the industry from BP
and tech to Repsol and Synovus are
making the same promise pledging to be
carbon neutral by 2050 all these large
companies really do have to be making
this sort of a move at this point there
is a huge Drive from the investment
community with very very large funds
having stated that they're not going to
nest in in fossil fuels and one of the
main reasons has to do with the
greenhouse gas emissions the Net Zero
pledge isn't it the same across the
board for a company like tech the
promise only covers its production
methods it's actually not that hard
they're not talking about you know
making their end product Net Zero
they're just saying our operations you
know by 2050 will no longer use oil and
gas to fuel them will no longer create
co2 emissions and to be honest I mean
the technology for that already exists
BP on the other hand is promising to
offset emissions from their products as
well a move that will require investing
more heavily away from oil so where does
that
a project like tech frontier the reality
is whatever the government ultimately
decides may be irrelevant the company
has said it needs oil prices to rise
significantly before commits to
investing in the project political will
aside at the moment the project just
doesn't make financial sense Heather
your ex west global news Calgary
recovered relapsed and repeat offenders
ahead calls for change in Canadian
prisons
here's a cold hard truth about the
majority of people convicted of crimes
and behind bars in this country they
have a history of substance abuse and
often don't get the support they need
yesterday we introduced you to an Ottawa
man Eliot Hudson who has been in and out
of jail and Rehab his story is not
unique
tonight we look at what has to change to
break the cycle abigail Beeman has part
two of our series addicted and
imprisoned addicts don't need to be
thrown in jail long before Elliot Hudson
sat behind bars he was passionate about
the criminalization of addictions he
wanted to write his master's thesis on
the topic he ended up living it a messy
cycle of rehab and relapse and
convictions it's extremely damaging
because when you relapse there's so much
shame and guilt that that just
perpetuates more using and and it
creates a cycle that's very very
difficult to get out of its a relapsing
illness if there's a relapse there
sometimes a concept of o.c treatment
doesn't really work but we don't do that
in other parts of healthcare the
psychiatrist in chief at the Royal
Ottawa Mental Health Centre says one of
the biggest challenges people with
addictions face is a lack of
understanding around treatment and
stigma still around three-quarters of
Canadian inmates in federal institutions
have a history of substance abuse access
to treatment can be a problem the amount
of money that is spent on treatment is
far too negligible when you look at the
nature and extent of the problem that's
the correctional investigator for the
federal prison system and in the
country's biggest province the latest
Auditor General's report says Ontario
jails are not suited to provide
appropriate care to inmates with mental
health issues and the number of those
inmates is on the rise not only are
people criminalized for things that they
have done when they've experienced
mental health struggles or drug use
issues that the way that the system
interacts with them often sets them up
for for failure the data is
pretty sparse on reoffending there are
so many other factors that play into it
but we do know that that retention and
treatment is a protective element dr.
lori regan Strief is an addictions
expert who's worked in Ontario jails she
sees people incarcerated all the time
with drug problems left unresolved they
go out and don't do well they go out and
they overdose I think I want me to come
back in again and it's all about really
not having those those needs addressed
as for Elliot Hudson he's still working
to address his needs he's checked back
into rehab at the Royal Ottawa and yes
he's been here before I've got a lot of
good things in my life today compared to
to where I was I may not be exactly
where I want it's still a journey
recovery doesn't happen overnight a
journey he hopes to share to help others
like him his story isn't over
Abigail Beaman global news Ottawa next
bullied to the brink of suicide one
boy's tragic story gets worldwide
attention we've reported many times on
the impact bullying has on kids we like
to think it happens less than it used to
but now a video has emerged from
Australia
a heartbreaking video that's hard to
watch the mother of a nine-year-old
indigenous boy posted it because she's
so worried Quaid unveils has dwarfism
he's constantly picked on by his peers
and talks about wanting to kill himself
since she posted it the response has
been overwhelming this is the effect
that bullying has this is what bullying
does it is so hard to watch yet it's
what Quaid unveils mother says she hears
from her son almost every day when she
picks him up from school and I've got a
son that he's suicidal almost every
single day this is what it is doing and
I want people to learn how much it is
hurting us as a family of a people to
educate their children she didn't want
to keep it hidden anymore wanted the
world to know how bullying can destroy
lives
this could be your child or your child
could be the bully that pushes a kid
over the edge being an Aboriginal boy
with a disability people don't
understand that's a double-edged sword
it's racism and then also discriminated
against because of a disability the
video now has more than 21 million views
the outpouring of love has been
overwhelming why deny that you are
important know that you are loved the
message amplified by celebrities like
actor Hugh Jackman quite you are
stronger than you know mine and no
matter what you got a friend in me
comedian Brad Williams who also has
dwarfism said the video makes him sick
and that Quaid in' has an army of
friends all over the world he set up a
GoFundMe page to send Weyden and his
mother on vacation to Disneyland more
than three hundred thousand dollars has
been raised so far and Quaid ins been
asked to lead the indigenous all-stars
Rugby League team onto the field for an
exhibition match on Sunday he said it
was going from the worst day of his life
to the best day of his life education
his mother says starts at home and she
and her son have just given the world a
powerful lesson and that is global
national for this Friday I'm Donna
Friesen tonight tear Canada is Wheatley
Ontario we'd love to see your Canada
please email it to viewers at global
national calm thanks for watching have a
lovely weekend and I'll see you back
here on Monday bye bye
[Music]
you